hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today we hit 15 million subscribers
yay
release the balloons battle aware of the
balloon this is the shittiest balloon
I've ever nothing I mean this is a
balloon you want to smack our big black
balloon again it's like a it's like a an
alarm you know ah yes
15 million subscribers I am inundated
with pride that the right word I'm swole
with pride anyway fifteen million
subscribers is a big deal like a really
big deal it's it's it's it's weird
because it's one of those numbers that
seems to have more meaning than other
numbers like 14 million was nice 13
million was cool but for some reason
because 15 million is an even number
it's not an even number actually 15
million is an even number
Oh 15 is not so yeah it's like it's a
meaningful number and I just wanted to
say thank you guys so much for getting
me to this milestone so quickly it's at
this point it's like ah man so many
people what do I do
like I feels like I should do something
important so I'm recommitting to
something that I've wanted to do for a
long time and I've made excuses for it
and I have no reason that I've made
excuses other than that life has been
crazy but now you see this the up all of
this it's not this is my new office
yay there's editing computers over there
this a TV back there that we're gonna
have a live feed of everyone who donates
on the stream we're gonna have like a
live feed going of names and pop ups and
animations go now back down back down
we're gonna have multiple cameras we got
lights we got a little bit of
soundproofing we're at these cool things
which have you been asking there they're
like super professional loves I mean you
can hear Tyler clear as day
not even here yeah ghost of Tyler oh god
is that a ghost no that is weird the way
the way the board goes on your mic
totally peak that's okay okay anyway
enough of [ __ ] around with that it's
um it's like an industrial loft that we
turned into this really cool stage
that's gonna be adaptable for number one
live streams number two group recordings
so when Bob and we'd come out here or
even Jack or anybody that wants to
record with us we have a couch for it we
have a recording TV and we have
recording commuters and live streaming
computers basically this is what I've
been talking about what I wanted to
build for a long time and I've never
really had is an office that's custom
designed and you should see these big
old soundproof curtains we have just
like slapped over there it's like a box
cuz it wasn't meant for it it's like
concrete and stuff you'll see like if we
have a show like the editing computers
like it's not meant for this but we made
it for it so this is what we've been
waiting for for so long and it's taken
longer than I thought but I've always
wanted to have like an outside office
that's separate from my home because
I've always recorded in my home and I've
always wanted to have something for us
to like go to and do this sort of stuff
in that's custom built specifically for
it and we finally added just Tyler get
over here okay anything like a weirdo
you're in he's not dead everybody I just
wanted to say thank you guys so much for
15 million subscribers and it's really
cool that right now finally this is
ready and we have a place where we can
work together a Tyler is here which I've
never actually explained why he's here
um yeah Tyler and I are working together
now and he keeps me on schedule and he
sets up all the stuff that we do he gets
all the stuff for these challenges and
he pushes me to stay on task for stuff
like that he's basically my boss I've
hired my boss he tells me what to do
every day they like mark us-- lazy sack
of [ __ ] why don't you get off your ass
and actually do something with your life
and he's gonna be helping set up all
these
charity events and we're gonna be doing
them every month from now on and also if
I have my foot throw me my phone
Jesus I don't care if you broke my phone
but don't hurt my diamond play button
all right hi chica
oh hi chica chica chica doesn't get out
of the house enough chica with ELISA see
chica when she first got in here she was
a Laker Oh oh my god everything is so
amazing what's hot here where's the air
conditioning god damn it we had to put
we had to install air conditioning in
this place because it was not ready for
air conditioned we basically have to do
a lot of [ __ ] to make this place work
but it's perfect it's beautiful we
repainted everything we like carpet down
because it was concrete floor it's
gorgeous I love this place it's perfect
but anyway we're gonna be doing monthly
live streams oh oh no that's what
happened not the diamond Oh God YouTube
I need another one cuz the diamond came
out [ __ ] god damn it that's not the say
bye girls hey YouTube clear give me
another one this is cheapest [ __ ] this
isn't real diamondden I don't want to do
that it's yours go for it I like a rock
literally I have we for the carving
pumpkins challenge we bought these
candles that are like Himalayan salt
rocks and we shot him like can you lick
these or are they poisonous and we
looked it up well actually no I licked
it before we looked enough like tastes
like salt well as they're licking at him
like I should probably look up he's
gonna kill me I looked it up it said
like he'll Malayan rock salt is super
healthy so I was like oh great so now I
just have a licking rod for everyday
purposes like before I record every day
I gotta bleep all right about go record
all right
don't judge me I should bring that here
su-kam he's unlucky oh just like every
life sibling we get $100 Oh dated
YouTube send me another one so just
thank you guys so much for 15 million
subscribers up with [ __ ] we're gonna be
doing all of our live streams and stuff
from here from now on
and it was originally gonna be decorated
more nicely but that is an actual
working TV we're gonna hook up to like
chat and for donations and we're gonna
have merchandise we're gonna bring back
pajama pants tiny buck stim plushies
we're gonna be doing all that for
charity and basically we're just gonna
be running a better series of live
streams and we are gonna be doing them
every month and the reason my phone
who's thrown over here and sacrifice my
play button for was so we could decide
when the next charity livestream was
gonna be so for November we don't have
enough though why is November completely
full see he he also runs the calendar I
never opened my calendar that's like all
day it's like oh my god what a [ __ ] is
this 19th does that work that works for
me the 19 so the November the 19th we're
gonna be streaming for crisis text line
from like 10 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
to 10 p.m. we're gonna have lots of
stuff going on we're gonna have guests
in here Tyler's gonna be helping me out
a bunch this is also gonna be the
challenge space so no more like in my
kitchen or in my backyard random
[ __ ] like we have a dedicated space
we're gonna have like cameras on the
ceiling we're gonna go pro setup it's
gonna be great all connected to these
computers here it's gonna be a lot of
fun so I can't wait to do so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for 15 million subscribers do you have
anything you'd like to say I want to
thank you guys because you're giving
Marc the opportunity to be able to do
what he originally intended to do on
YouTube and you essentially gave me an
opportunity to come out here and help
him sure Katherine and Nathan would say
the same thing
Thank You Marc and thanking you guys for
everything you've done yeah so thanks
again just from the bottom of our hearts
you guys really have done
amazing thing and I can't wait to
dedicate myself back into like just this
huge sphere of doing good for the world
and also having fun along the way and
making even bigger and better and
stupider videos so thanks again
everybody and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye bye
oh nice